the college school year that just ended
was packed with seemingly endless
controversies involving everything from
banning the movie American sniper to
questioning Columbia University's
mattress girl to using title 9 a federal
law designed to end gender
discrimination to investigate feminist
professor Laura Kipnis at Northwestern
Robbie suave is a staff editor covers
higher education and free speech issues
at reason.com
we sat down to talk with him about three
of the most disturbing campus stories of
the year and why there's reason to
believe that the high tide of political
correctness is actually receding let's
start first with the case of Emma Sol
quits at Columbia she's better known as
mattress girl what was going on there
and how is the case shakin out yeah this
is a case that's really brought a lot of
renewed attention to this issue of
sexual assault on campuses in Emma
sulker with this case she so she accused
her a friend of hers and they'd become
lovers Paul Nungesser of assaulting her
while they were having intercourse
early on her sophomore year of college
and then months later she made the
accusations when she says that other
friends of her said they had also been
assaulted by him there's you know this
is a very disputed incident the only two
people in the room were them he says she
made the whole thing up and ultimately
the campus judiciary process did side
with him and said that you know he
didn't do it and the police you know
didn't go much further than looking into
it and saying like there's not enough
here to support the charge that he did
do it and then she as an art project she
started carrying a mattress around with
her around campus called carried that
way right
and that obviously drew a lot of
attention what what happened now because
Nungesser graduated right as did she she
both graduated they both graduated and
she did bring her mattress with her
across the stage and interestingly the
president of Columbia Lee Bollinger
didn't shake her hand as she crossed I
think cuz she caused so much trouble for
them including being one of the students
who filed a Title 9 complaint against
the University this is the the law that
you know forbids sexual discrimination
and harassment on campus in this case I
mean you have a sexual assault or you
know a claim of sexual assault and it
ends up leading to two Title VII cases
one by the woman involved one by the man
and what is the status of non guessers
case then against Columbia yeah so it's
just pending and at this point was filed
a couple weeks ago it argues that he
that the university failed to protect
him from the campaign of harassment that
she waged against him by you know
publicly identifying him by by making
this statement aimed at getting him
kicked off campus and he was saying that
you know I'm innocent of this I was
found innocent of this and they had and
they sponsored her project as well
because she received course credit for
it it was an art project on campus I
would do is there a timeline for when
this might play out legally it's it's
hard to tell and it's hard to tell
frankly whether whether it is merited
because you could make the argument that
she was engaging in crude right speech
and advocacy although the fact that she
received course credit for it
complicates it a little bit and the
lawsuit doesn't actually you know he's
not suing her right a complaint
another recent story was at a couple of
colleges including your alma mater
University of Michigan had they were
going to show American sniper at
Michigan a Muslim student group
protested the university pulled the
viewing then put it back on what does
this tell us about the current state of
free expression or and I'm not even sure
if it's very expression but of just kind
of open discussion on college campuses
right I think it's a frightening a
little bit to see the definition of
what's you know what's threatening you
know lowered to such an extent because
the students were saying literally
showing this movie would make us feel
unsafe on campus that this is a genocide
Allah
you know anti-muslim propaganda film
which I don't know that that's the case
but in a sense I'm like even if it was
couldn't wouldn't we be isn't a
university a good place to to study it
and you
maybe denounce it if it's terrible or
you know talk about to work are you
there yet teach the conflicts right you
know exactly yeah how did the students
the Muslim students get a band and then
what happened that it went you know the
university was like now we're going to
show it anyway
right they they did a petition and
generated a lot of a lot of media buzz
and that you know that got it anyway was
a it was a recreational campus affiliate
group affiliated with university was
going to show it they got them to
reverse that decision and then there was
some counter blow back to that people
going like are you out of your mind and
a football coach at Michigan Harbaugh
was very supportive of actually showing
it right yeah if you're being led by
your football coach in the arena free
speech right something has gone right so
they did show they showed paddington as
well was the alternative film which is a
little ironic you know kind of based on
a children's yeah sort of thing a final
case to talk about is the the Strange
Case of Laura Kipnis she's a professor
at Northwestern University who became
the subject or the target of a title 9
complaint at Northwestern what did she
do that raised the ire of students there
this is really an astonishing case
because all she did was write an op-ed
in The Chronicle of Higher Education
that was about title 9 in general and
she's a she's a liberal a radical sort
of you know old 60s style person who was
actually writing about you know being
more sexually open and permissive right
and and this the students supposedly
liberal students didn't like it they
complained about the op-ed they thought
it was factually wrong they protested
and they also filed title 9 complaint
against her and then what happened with
that could say if a title 9 complaint is
is lodging and somebody than the
university investigates it and
northwestern found what yeah they after
hiring outside law firm you know that
talk to her with her support person not
her lawyer but her person she's allowed
to bring who was replaced midway through
the process because he also had he had
issues so he generated title 9
complaints against him so it's really
astonishing to see them kind of just
take off but she was cleared so what was
she
technically accused of I mentioned of
creating an unsafe it was a hostile
place she was retaliating there were a
couple issues but it was that she was
retaliating against against the person
who was named in the title nine
complaint that she was discussing it was
retaliating against them and that's not
allowed under title nine and it was
creating a chilling effect for people to
file title nine complaints that she was
complaining about title and of course
then the flip of that is that this
creates a chilling effect on the speech
of everybody I might as if everything
you say is subject to a to a complaint
that is then going to go through some
kind of adjudication
right some time of adjudication process
and think of the I can think of the
expense how this must drive up the cost
of college tuition that they have to
respond to every single instance of
someone's stepping a toe out of line now
the one of the things I was interesting
about Kipnis is that this is not the
kind of stalking you know the the kind
of political correctness argument from
maybe ten or fifteen years ago because
you have a liberal professor a left-wing
feminist professor who's being attacked
she was talking you know among other
things in The Chronicle of Higher
Education P she was talking about how
students should be more sexually
liberated and she remembered fondly
instances where she engaged in sex with
her professors back in the day and so
this was a different type of case and it
God a very she was highly defended by
all sorts of people that normally kind
of glom you know kind of pile on the
professor in this case why you know what
happened there and what what role did
that play yeah well some people you know
cynically said that it was well liberals
are now willing to defend because it's a
liberal professor who's the victim I
think that's a little too cynical I
think you are seeing a cross across the
board kind of concern from commentators
from pundits from other journalism
outlets that there really is something
wrong with the climate on campus when
people for expert really just all
they're doing is expressing opinions
there was no instance you know Laura
Kipnis didn't there's no physical
dispute with anyone she really just
talked about what she thought and I
think that's starting to create a
movement that wants to do something
about it unfortunately because of the
title nine
regime because of how the Education
Department has interpreted this law
there's really not much we can do I
think until until that law is kind of
engaged beyond the kind of Kipnis
incident there's also Jonathan shade of
the new of writer magazine recently
wrote a you know a basic liberal
commentator you know talked about PC
going too far there are other instances
of this are we entering a phase where
you know the idea of kind of enforcing
orthodoxy through the suppression of
speech seems to be you know being called
into question more than it has been yeah
I definitely think you see you see that
and you can the number of pieces like
Jonathan Chait making that argument on
the other on the other hand there are
still you know a lot of people who are
concerned that you know campuses should
be more accommodating and emotionally
accommodating you know we really need to
you know treat kids like children and so
you do see those arguments being made
but I think the the stronger argument
that that colleges are places where you
should you know really really be
troubled you should be provoked you
should be angry you should engage you
know a a range of views and that's kind
of a you know a classically liberal sort
of mindset and I think that argument is
being made by a lot more people with in
reaction to kind of these crazy story
after story alright well we'll leave it
there robbie suave of reason thanks for
talking to us thank you and for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie